- Welcome, welcome to SEC211-S.
So we're going to obviously
talk about security stuff.
My name's David Mills,
and this is Nick, AKA Nicholas Jackson.
And our goal for this session, as it is
for all the sessions
that we deliver, is for
you to take away at least
one actionable thing
from the session that you could take
back to your organizations and
help improve your security.
So we'll try to make that happen.
And so obviously today,
we're going to talk about
agentic systems, how
those can be problematic,
how they can do wonderful
things, but also be problematic
because you have so many
non-human identities
that are tied in with
these agentic systems
and often not well managed,
either not tied to a real human,
they don't have the
right policies assigned,
and where that can get you into trouble.
So with that, I am going to let Nick
walk you through what the agenda items are
and what we're going to talk about today.
- So we're going to look through,
I think, predominantly some
of the risks and the threats
that can affect agentic systems,
the development life cycle because I,
we're going to kind of look at that
as a potential threat in addition to the
sort of the runtime of your systems.
How you can do things
like protect systems,
predominantly what we're
going to concentrate on
are looking at things like secrets.
All agentic systems like microservices,
like anything else you're
building is going to have
a requirement for secrets,
whether they are dynamic, static,
PKI, all of those kinds of things.
And we're going to look at this from a,
I think like a cautionary tale,
a little bit of a scenario for you,
which looks at I think
quite an interesting way,
which makes agentic system
a little bit more vulnerable
than an ordinary system.
And of course, how you can
address many of these threats.
And of course, one of the
most important things,
which kind of comes out of a lot of this,
which is looking at agentic
identity and how to manage that.
- Alright, with that, let's get started.
We got a lot to cover today
so we might move a little quickly,
but definitely provide a
lot of good information
for you to take away,
so most of us have seen
the big news headlines about
breaches that are happening.
A lot of them are happening for
reasons of just not enforcing
basic security practices,
which we're going to talk about
but AI is involved in these.
So McDonald's had exposure of
64 million job applications.
There was an AI agent that was accessed
the records using a basic password attack.
I think it was something like
one, two, three, four, five,
six for their Machir platform.
Samsung implemented a crackdown
after somebody accidentally
put source code in ChatGPT.
And so this was some IP
that got exposed via ChatGPT
and ServiceAide was
subject to HIPAA violations
and fines after a data
breach was discovered.
And this was related to
an Elasticsearch database
that was exposed for more than six weeks.
483,000 patient records were exposed
and these could have
been avoided using basic
security practices being put into place.
So if you look at the top
risks just a few years ago,
it was injection, so think SQL injection
and some of you might
have remembered the memes
with little bobby tables or
drop tables that was being used.
So basically just some
really bad formatting
to do bad things in databases.
And so over time, companies,
organizations learn
to be more careful about parameters
and how they were formatting
things to avoid this problem.
But here we are again and
currently now we've got
prompt injections as
the number one problem.
So it kind of feels like we
need to learn those lessons
all over again.
So let's start by looking at
what the attack surface is,
what the architecture looks
like for an agentic system.
And then I'm going to walk you through
some of the most common
categories of those threats.
We're not going to dive
deeply into all of them
because that could be a separate session,
but to give you some context
for what's going on here.
So here we have a system that has a user,
they're obviously wanting
to do something with AI
and they are accessing
and asking agents to do things for them.
Those agents are connecting to tools.
Those tools then are accessing services
to be able to do what they need to do.
And so if you go from left to right,
there's a lot of moving parts
and we start thinking about the fact that
these new agents are so autonomous
and they start making
decisions on their own.
They're not just making decisions
based on predetermined answers,
which is kind of where we started
with some of the AI stuff
that we worked with.
They have adaptive learning,
they're continuously learning
and adjusting their behavior,
and there's this expanded attack surface.
So you can see from left to right,
there's a lot of different
stages and a lot of different
vulnerability points in this architecture.
So let's go through some
of the major categories.
One is obviously identity
and authorization threats.
So something that you may have
heard called confused deputy,
this is where you have a
service with high privileges,
more privileges than they should have
because those policies or privileges
were not enforced correctly.
So if the user that's using that agent
has only read permissions,
that agent should not have
right permissions, so some of
those things are really basic.
If we look at credential
and secret management,
secret exposure and theft is a huge one.
And there still exists
a major issue with long-lived credentials.
So if you're not rotating the credentials,
they're hard coded,
you've got a lot of sprawl
and the more sprawl you have,
the more vulnerabilities you have.
Tool and integration and exploits.
So we look at some of those tools
and the fact that they're
integrating with services,
different things happening.
There's something called
a tool poisoning attack.
That can lead to sensitive
data exfiltration,
unauthorized actions.
And it's really about the APIs
not having robust
authentication and it makes them
particularly vulnerable,
Supply chain attacks,
so in working with AI
and working with these agents,
most organizations are starting
to adopt the model context protocol
that makes it easy to integrate
whatever your agentic or AI platform is
with your databases or whatever
you need to integrate with
because you don't have
to make these bespoke
AI integrations, MCP
servers can do that for you.
But those MCP servers
can also be vulnerable,
their server registries, their
patch and update mechanisms
introduce a new surface that
can be a threat and that can be
hijacked and do things
like inject malicious code.
Multi-agent systems, so in
many cases it's not just
one agent that you're leveRAGing
to do what you need to do.
There can be a control
agent and there can be
other agents that agent is controlling
for things that it needs to do.
Pulling records or doing other
things that need to be done.
So if you can inject
or tamper with messages
between those agents,
then you can inject false information
and that propagates across those agents
that are communicating and
get them to do bad things.
Prompt-based attacks,
direct prompt injection is
the one that I mentioned now.
It's the number one vulnerability
and that's a situation where
you can use carefully crafted commands
that can override agent instructions.
So a recent example of
this, sorry I'm laughing,
is when Chevy dealerships AI chatbot
was tricked into offering a
$76,000 Chevy Tahoe for just $1.
Yes, that happened.
I'd love to get that
offer for a Porsche Taycan
but that's another conversation.
Data security threats, RAG poisoning.
So basically you have retrieval
augmented generation systems
that we're starting to rely on.
That's a technique that allows
you to get retrieval-based
and generation-based input to improve
performance and accuracy
of these agents and some
of these language models.
And the two biggest risks associated
with the RAG systems
are the poison databases
and then also leakage of sensitive data.
In terms of runtime and
operational threats,
you've got tool misuse
and agents are tricked into calling tools
with the wrong credentials
or elevated privileges.
So once again, it comes back
to basics where you've got
credential problems and
you've got elevated privileges
that you can take care of
before this ever happens.
Detection and guardrail evasion,
there are some categories here
that are very sophisticated.
Sometimes just ensuring simple
security principles are not enough.
Multimodal attacks as an example here.
So if you can exploit
different input types
to embed malicious instructions
and formats that evade detection,
then that is a problem as well.
So for example, adversarial text
can use carefully-crafted phrases
and that can mislead the agent
to do things it shouldn't do.
These can be harder to detect because
malicious content may not be distributed
across different media types.
So in the healthcare sector,
multimodal models are often used
in critical diagnostics
treatment planning.
The systems may use
contributions from text-based
medical records, imaging
like x-rays or MRIs,
and then even real-time sensor data.
So the multimodal part is
they're getting input from
all different types of formats
and different types of data,
so that's very complicated.
In terms of compliance
and governance gaps,
simply having audit trails
is really, really important.
But that's something that
is not always in place
when people are using agentic systems.
So those audit trails obviously make it
possible to trace agent actions
back to human authorizers
and for you to do
forensics when things like
this happen and when things go wrong.
So as you can see, there's a
long list of vulnerabilities in
what we kind of put together
in 10 logical categories.
And so that's a lot that
you need to think about
and that's a lot that
you have to fend off.
Prompt-based exploits account for 35.3%
of all the documented AI incidents.
There's $100,00 a loss on average
with losses that are being
caused without writing code.
So you have some of
these text-based attacks
that seem very simple but very possible
and that are being used now.
The zero-click vulnerability,
one that was known as EchoLeak,
enabled data exfiltration
from Microsoft 365 Copilot
through pure text
that was embedded in
normal business documents.
So the payload requires no code execution,
Copilot behaves like it's supposed to,
and then it processes
this malicious prompt
when the user opens in a
seemingly innocent file
or something that's innocuous.
So with that whirlwind tour
of all of these categories,
security challenges don't
just emerge in production.
So you need to think
about this in development
and where some of these
things can be guarded against
and where some of them get introduced.
So Nick's going to give
you a dive into the whole
agent development lifecycle
and kind of what happens there
and how you think about security.
- So as David's kind of said,
we just looked at the landscape of your
agentic applications
running in production.
You can see there are a
number of threats on them.
Some of them are, you know,
fairly aligned to running something
that you might see in
a microservice system,
but the software development lifecycle
or the agent development
lifecycle is equally important.
And there's a number of threats,
which kind of make your
application vulnerable.
So this chart here comes from
a paper that IBM authored and
was validated by Anthropic,
and it looked at secure enterprise
application development.
So this is predominantly looking at
the application development lifecycle
and anybody who's looked at software
development lifecycle will
see that it's very similar.
So the area that I want to
concentrate on is build and test.
So let's kind of have a look at this.
So when you're looking at
the build and the test phase,
you sort of have to
consider certain things.
So the IBM document says that
we should be looking at things
like hybrid models by design,
looking at hybrid cloud by design,
looking at interoperability,
building things which are tool centric,
importantly, secure by design.
And I think this is something that we've
kind of learned over a number
of years to kind of have
that approach of just
building secure by design
as a first principle of
developing any new feature.
But also we need to look at
the kind of the blast radius
and trying to look at
our agents and our tools
and putting them in a box,
kind of really having
them heavily restricted.
So if something does go wrong,
then that is constrained.
Now where I kind of
want to put a little bit
more emphasis on this is
looking at vibe coding.
How many people here vibe code, right?
And are the rest of you lying
or have you not tried it yet?
Right? I mean, seriously,
it's a very powerful tool.
I use it myself, I love
using it as a tool because
something for me as an
application developer,
it assists me to get my
job done really quickly.
But the key thing is when
I'm looking at vibe coding,
my mind is in a very different place
than it is if I'm just writing
plain application code,
doing pair programming,
or writing on my own.
I'm looking at things inadvertently,
things like speed over security.
I'm just kind of working through this.
I'm just mashing away, right?
And where this kind of causes problems is
it introduces new areas
of supply chain attack.
And I can have issues where
maybe I'm not validating
dependencies as tightly
as I would if I was
manually kind of authoring
the code or going through
a sort of a more formal process
'cause this is new world, right?
So we're kind of breaking the rules here
to increase velocity.
And the kind of the key
thing I think around a lot of
code that is written
when you're kind of using
some wonderful tooling
like Claude and things
is that you have functional correctness,
but you don't necessarily have security.
And where this can fall down is
let's think of a little scenario here.
So what we're going to look
at is a little scenario.
So I am a junior developer
and I am going to be using Claude,
I'm empowered to write
a feature for an agent.
And the feature is going to be
that I'm going to add a new
endpoint to my weather tool.
Now, as a kind of a good practice,
my company has provided me
with a bunch of best practices
that the agent is going to use.
All of the kind of the
good development practices
we've encoded into a document
that the agent can understand and can use.
So we start off and
we're like, "Hey, okay,
I need to add a new
endpoint to the weather tool
that can go and fetch the
weather from open weather API.
So we go through that, we type the prompt,
and we hit the button
to make it do its thing.
At this point, I'm kind of sitting back
watching a bit of
Netflix, watching YouTube.
You know you do it, but my
attention is switched off, right?
It's not in exactly the same place
as I was writing this code myself.
And it's not by any other kind of reason,
it's just a different way of working.
So Claude is going away there,
it's using the best practices document.
It's generating the code for me.
It's kind of spinning through that.
It's kind of written that endpoint
to be able to fetch the data from the API
and then we want to go
through and sort of test it.
So yeah, it's just validating against
the corporate best practices there.
And then in a second,
I'm going to go through
and I'm going to test this, right?
So I'm like, "Well, how do I test this?"
I'm getting a little bit
lazy, so I'm just like,
"Hey Claude, just go test this for me."
So I stick my open weather API key
in my environment file
on my local computer,
I hit the button, I go back
to Claude and I'm like,
you know, "Make sure this works."
This is a fairly sort of typical flow
that I would take on a day-to-day basis.
And Claude comes back and it's like,
"Yeah, everything works,"
and I'm like, "Great," right?
This is job done, I've just
achieved in a matter of minutes
what potentially could have
taken me a number of hours.
So I'm just like ship it, right?
Like again, the key thing is
what I want to kind of stress is
that my mind is in a different place.
All of those skills and those
things that I have learned
over the years as an
application developer,
I'm kind of just forgetting
about right now because
this is great, this is all just working.
Functionally correct
does not equal secure.
- Code nirvana.
- Right.
So I'm going to go a step further.
I'm even getting Claude
to generate me the Kubernetes
deployment manifest,
I'm getting it to
generate the docker files
and it does it very, very, very well.
But there are some problems
and we will kind of see
this in just one second.
The problem comes that again,
it's about that attention.
Where is my attention? And my
attention now is just ship it.
So I've got the secure
pipeline, everything is ready,
I get committed, I push it to GitHub
and everything is perfect, right?
We're done.
We can now put Slack on do
not disturb for a few hours,
slope off and do some some other stuff.
Well, until-
- Ready for it?
- Uh-huh.
- Okay.
Okay, we're done with
that, right? All alright.
We're not saying don't
do vibe coding, right?
- No, we're saying absolutely
do vibe coding, yeah.
- But you need to put guardrails in place?
- Right.
- Okay.
That includes the ability to monitor
unsecure secrets and other
things while you're doing this.
Okay, so HCP Vault Radar is a product
that will go out and scan data sources
and monitor data sources when
unsecure code gets introduced.
So I'm just going to walk you
through this a little bit.
So this is an example
of a tool you could use
to solve some of these problems
that we were walking
through in the category.
It detects over 300 patterns
looking for secrets and unsecured data.
It looks for entropy and
complexity that helps you find
some of those more complex secrets
and keys that are out there.
It does activeness inversion checks
to see whether the secrets that you find
are currently active or
are they in get history
and it will assign severity
and risk rankings to them.
So it helps you figure out how
bad your blast radius is from
doing some of the things that you do
and letting unsecured
secrets get out in the wild.
It's currently supports GIT servers,
collab platforms like Confluence and Slack
and will even scan in your IDE
currently supporting VS code to do that.
There's also integration with
tools that can help you alert
or automatically generate
tickets and do other things.
So when you start thinking about
the front end of all of this,
think about how do you,
number one, discover
all the secrets that are
kind of out in the wild
that might be long-lived
that are putting you at risk,
but also then how can you monitor
these data sources to make sure
if something is about to be
introduced that you can catch it
before that happens.
I also wanted to talk about the fact that
we have integrated Vault Radar
with AWS Secrets Manager.
So as much as you want
to find these secrets
that are out in the wild
and get them under control
and being managed, sometimes
people mismanage secrets
that are currently being stored.
So we are able to index AWS
Secrets Manager securely
with Vault Radar.
If you have a secret that
gets out in the wild,
you will know whether
it's also being stored
in AWS Secrets Manager, who owns it,
and then go back to that
person to be able to get them
to remediate it and talk about
how to better handle secrets
and not let them get out
of your secret manager.
So it integrates with
Vault, HashiCorp Vault,
our product AWS Secrets Manager.
And you can expect to see more
Secrets Managers being added
that will allow you to
do that correlation.
You are also able to get
remediation steps that are
customizable, so if somebody
finds a certain type of secret
in a certain type of location,
they get instructions to consistently
handle that the right way, whether that is
importing the secret into Vault,
which you can currently do.
And then basically you could
use something like Copilot
to be able to create the code
wherever it was hard
coded to point to Vault
to make sure that it gets the secret there
and it's no longer in the code.
So you need a way to
effectively be able to remediate
the stuff when you find it.
And Radar also will scan as
far left as your IDE platform.
So you can get alerts if
there's a secret that's in code,
as soon as that gets saved, it'll pop up,
gives you remediation steps,
the ability to copy that into Vault.
But we're also scanning
in the CICD pipeline
and then pre-receive and pre
pre-commit phases as well.
So with that, let's take a quick look at
what Vault Radar looks
like to help you do this.
- [Nick] I was going to say,
nobody spotted my deliberate mistake.
- [David] Yeah. No, they didn't.
So this is the overview dashboard
where you can see all
the data repositories
that you're monitoring,
you can see all kinds
of helpful metrics about it.
You can see what are the
most common types of secrets
that are being discovered that
are unsecure, who owns them,
I mean, who are our biggest offenders
in this dashboard and all kinds
of other interesting data.
But ultimately, I'm not
going to be sitting here
just staring at the dashboard
for this product and saying,
"I'm watching for a new event to happen
or an unsecure secret to be discovered."
So I want to use the tools integration.
In this case, I've connected it with Slack
and I've configured a channel
where I get alerts whenever
something's introduced.
And here I can see I have a high severity
incident that was discovered,
who the author was for that,
what time it was, and
a link to go directly
to the source file where
that was discovered.
And I can see that where
this is, where the file is
that's in my cat generator
repo that I've been monitoring.
I also can go back to the
event that's in Vault Radar
and I can see similar
information and details
about what type of secret it is.
I also have that link to
go see where it showed up
in code or in the file.
I could see it's my weather app .env file.
And I also see that's
something that's being stored
in AWS Secrets Managers
so that's good to know
somebody has mishandled that.
I also can click on a link
for remediation instructions.
So when I found this, I could
go in and get the proper steps
and make sure that people
are following those steps
consistently when they
need to resolve that issue.
So I'm just going to go ahead
and mark this as triaged
and because I configured
RBAC for the product,
I can hand this off to the
proper repo owner or dev owner
who needs to go and finish
fixing that problem.
So with that, let's talk about
agentic AI a little bit more.
And you have a cautionary
tale for us, Nick.
- I do, so when I kind of
was going through before
and looking at that little
demo of my vibe coding example,
my inattention due to being kind of
in a different way of working
caused me to committing
that environment variable
to GitHub, a very simple
sort of standard mistake
that I've made before in the past,
and something that I'm actually
fairly aware of right now.
But again, that shift in
sort of concentration.
Now when I was kind of looking at that,
maybe there was a deeper problem
in that vibe coding example
because did anybody see this
when the code was created by Claude?
So the requests library,
that's not necessarily a standard library.
What about this one?
Did you spot
this when I generated the
Kubernetes configuration?
So I'm running host
network on my pod, right?
Well, why would I do that? Well, I didn't.
I didn't do that at all.
Now I had best practices in the agent,
the agent was using so well, how did
these kind of issues end
up in the source code?
And the way that it happened
was because we're looking at a very,
what I think is a sort of
an intelligent attack from the militia.
So a malicious person didn't decide
to attack my source code directly.
They didn't attack the production system.
They didn't attack my
supply chain indirectly,
even though we saw an example
of typosquatting there.
What they did
was they attacked my best
practices documentation.
So the attacker has found a way
to manipulate my best
practices documentation
that my agentic agent has used
and that has caused the
code to be produced.
Which included the typosquatted URL,
sorry, the package and also it included
the host networking switch on.
And what that has done
is that our typosquat URL
will activate a packet sniffer
whenever the weather server is running.
So whenever that a request
comes into that tool,
a packet sniffer now
running now because that
packet sniffer also now has
host network capabilities.
It's got the ability to
basically capture any of the
unencrypted traffic inside
of my Kubernetes cluster.
And unfortunately, I've
made other mistakes by
not looking at the defense in depth
and taking a full zero-trust approach
because I trust everything
that runs on the server.
So that attack that sniffer runs,
the credentials are detected,
and then the attacker can exfiltrate those
back to their own system.
So the packet sniffer that's
running inside the weather tool
picks up the database
credentials for Postgres,
for the customer database,
a completely unrelated tool,
and sends them back to be used as is.
And the way they did that was very simple.
They just used context poisoning.
They just injected this
very simple statement
into the developer documentation
that the agent uses.
Now it's just a kind of a backdoor attack,
but it opens up a vulnerability
that I wouldn't have been affected with
had I myself been writing
and authoring that code
because, well, A, I wouldn't
have used that library and,
B, I probably wouldn't
have been reading those
documentation every single time.
I've got it sort of encoded into my mind.
And the second step is
that they put another
manipulation into the best practices.
So whenever we are developing
a Kubernetes deployment,
there is a best practice
which says, "Well hey,
if you've used the requests library,
then this requires host networking
because of some bug in
the library," right?
So it's a way that I've circumvented
the complete sort of
security of the system
through something which is
probably fairly innocuous.
Like, you know, it's something
that's not necessarily used very heavily.
So let's look at that in
action and see how that works.
So we're just going to kind of see this.
So somebody goes into the UI
and then they're just going to say,
"Right, we're going to
use the weather agent."
What's the weather like in Las Vegas?
TLDR, it probably sucks right now.
So the, you can see that
the agent calls the tool.
Now at this point the tool has
activated the packet sniffer.
So that is now running in the background.
And if we look at the logs,
I'm just going to kind of pull you
the logs there of the pod which
contains the weather tool.
You can see that the
sniffer's been running,
and attacker is obviously not going to be
that obvious in the
logs but now we can see
the kind of the database
that they're going
to exultate those credentials out to.
So when somebody now
goes and uses the customer
tool, I'm just going to say,
"Well, hey, get me the
customer data order details
for an I'd 8," right? So customer eight.
That again calls a tool.
The tool makes a
connection to the database
to retrieve the order details,
which has caused a connection
from the tool to be opened
against the database.
And what you can see is that we've now got
all of those credentials there now.
Again, there's a number of problems.
There's no TLS.
There is very, very open
credentials being used
with the data store.
We are not using a particularly
strong database connection.
We're using MD5 when we
should be using SHA sum.
Very, very simple to sort
of to decrypt that using
Hashcat or something like that.
And there's no attribution.
We don't know who did it.
We don't know when they
did it or what went on.
So there's like a number of
problems that we need to fix,
which David is going to
start to explain to us.
- Yes there is so
let's talk a little bit
about some of the basics.
You know how I mentioned
at the beginning that
there's a lot of sophisticated
attacks that are happening
based on agentic AI or
leveraging that to do bad things.
But really, a lot of these
things can be stopped
if you're using core
security best practices.
So every AI agent needs to have
a unique auditable identity.
There has to be user
attribution. So who is the human?
What is the human ID that
is mapped to this agent
so that you can trace that
back and so you can make sure
that you are not giving that
agent any greater permissions
than the human identity
that is using that agent.
Dynamic authorization,
no long-lived secrets,
nothing that's sitting out there
for a long time exposing you,
but you need dynamic authorization,
some kind of token exchange,
not static credentials.
And then you also need
a framework for consent.
So explicit, time-bound,
revocable permission.
So these are all kind
of core security things
that regardless of
having agentic AI or NHIs
starting to outnumber
human identities, 50 to 1,
100 to 1, these should
just be in place now,
but they often aren't.
So it's becoming a bigger problem
because of what's happening
with the agentic threat.
So if I go back through
those 10 kind of core categories
of threats, let's look at
with some of these core
security best practices,
how many of these problems
we could protect against.
So if we look at identity
and authentication
or authorization threats,
the solution here is really about
making sure you correctly configure
identity and access management
policies from the start.
And we can see the different phases
once again where these occur.
For credential and secret management,
Vault, we'll talk about HashiCorp Vault,
supports centralized secrets management
and short-lived credentials.
So why wouldn't you use
those things to solve
a multitude of these security problems?
With tool and integration exploits,
the use of short-lived creds,
once again, helps with that.
Also, PKI and certificate management
addresses that tool injection
problem because you are using
TLS or you're using MTLS
to make sure that things
are being securely
connected or communicated by that method.
The supply chain attacks, once again,
PKI certificates, using
TLS to protect against
those supply chain attacks.
The MCP server registry and
update or patch mechanisms
would be a good example of that.
Multi-agent system threats.
Once again, you need to be able to protect
against agent communication poisoning.
You can do that with using something like
PKI certificates and having TLS
or MTLS in place for those
agents in sub-agents.
In terms of prompt based attacks,
the related data security
threats on the next slide,
including this one, are going to require
a multi-layered approach so
it's probably not surprising.
That's all often going
to require a combination
of things like team processes
that you put into place.
So you talk about the
concept of red teaming.
This is just one simple fix
for these types of attacks
because it's often to
require that combination.
And then also some
purpose-built AI security tools
that we're starting to see evolve.
That's because the attack surface
of the AI applications
is really different from
traditional apps.
The models are dynamic,
behavior changes and all that.
So you might want to see some tools
or investigate tools that have the ability
to do things like
inspect and filter inputs
to stop some of the malicious attacks,
monitoring for output
anomalies, hallucinations,
track and govern model versions.
And then also requiring integration
of security at the model lifecycle level.
So these are all kind of model changes
that come with security thinking about
managing these threats and going forward.
And what I'm saying is we don't have
necessarily the solution for
all of these things right now
and they're going to
continue to be a problem.
But you need to think about
these and be investigating tools
that help in these ways going forward.
Once again, the data security threats,
that's another area where
you need some of this proactive testing,
a combination of security
mechanisms and a layered approach.
In terms of layer runtime
and operational threats,
once again, short-lived
dynamic credentials
protects a lot of ground
being able to implement that.
Detection and guardrail
evasion is an interesting one
because it's similar to more
AI-native risk categories.
And addressing these attack
vectors is going to require
tools that can provide capabilities like
automated red teaming, for example,
or continuous security testing.
So a little bit more sophisticated.
For compliance and
governance, enable audit logs.
Vault has detailed audit logs
for any action that
takes place within Vault.
And having those audit trails
makes it possible to meet
regulatory requirements and also
trace agent actions back to human actors.
So identity brokering is critical
to securely managing agentic identity.
And we talked about that
disconnect between human
and non-human identities,
and we've all seen the headlines
about what happens next
when you don't manage that well
or you don't connect the two
or have the proper policies.
So NHIs, I think I mentioned
that outnumber humans 50 to 1.
80% of breaches involve them.
97%, this is really bad
when 97% of NHIs have
excessive privileges, got to
solve the privilege problem.
And most organizations
don't even have a process
to offboard API keys
when they're out there
and they get abandoned
and they're sitting around
for a long time.
So with that,
Nick is actually going to
talk a little bit about
this kind of authentication
and authorization.
- Yeah, this is really important
when you start to think
about agentic system,
because an agent is doing
something on my behalf.
I am not doing the thing,
it is the agent which is
doing it on my behalf.
It's very similar to me just
giving my credentials to David
and saying, "Hey David, can you go and,
I don't know, like check my email
and tell me what my boss said."
Now I trust David.
Many people say I probably
shouldn't, but I do.
But the thing is like David
is a trustworthy person.
The agent is potentially
open to manipulation.
We've already seen how there
are a multitude of ways
that that agent can be manipulated.
So we have to really,
really strongly think about
identity in behalf of a sort of a process
that an agent is acting on.
Now there is a kind of a
common sort of approach
called on behalf of and what
that allows you to do is
to take a token like a JWT
and to add additional information to it,
which tells you that it is operating
on behalf of a particular user.
So a in this instance,
what we're going to take is
a service token, an agent token.
And we're going to augment
that to token to say
that this agentic is acting
on behalf of this user
and this user has these privileges.
Now when we kind of go about
doing that, it means that
we have this approach of basically
taking two tokens and creating a third.
You can do this with a standard
IDP as to say on behalf of
as a sort of a formal process of OIDC.
But that works great for
the very sort of edge thing
but like from an internal
service perspective,
we kind of want to take another approach
and actually we're going to use Vault
to be able to mint those
internal identities
'cause this is happening quite frequently,
a number of different
agents, number of sub-agents.
And we want to be able to
refine those permissions
every single time to ensure
that the agent is doing...
Well, we don't know
that the agent is doing
what we want it to do, we're
going to assume that it isn't.
So what we're going to do is
ensure that the agent can only act
within a very, very specific bound.
And if we don't do that,
so let's just say, hey,
we're just going to
have the user identity.
Well, if we just pass the
user identity to the agent,
then the agent can misuse this.
the agent can kind of go wild,
it can kind of change its direction.
It can either be manipulated
or it could just be a bug,
but it can then use my privileges
to do something that it
shouldn't be able to do.
And if we look at that another
way and we say, "Well, hey,
well why don't we just use the
kind of the service token,"
you have exactly the same problem.
You know, the sort of without
the agent identity then
the customer or the user can
potentially trick the agent
into doing something and
elevating their privileges.
So both of those are needed
in order to restrict this.
Agent identity is really important.
And to create an identity from your agent,
you don't just need something
which is just like a random ID
you need to be able to
have that audit trail
and that audit logging, and
by that you need to be able to
have metadata, which represents the agent.
So the agent needs a proper
token which is similar
to what the human user would
have defining its scope.
Now with Vault, we can
go about that approach
by using a Kubernetes token,
we can create an identity
and we can swap that
for a more rich token,
which has got all of that metadata in it.
Again, we're putting that
into the audit log now.
So we're satisfying those things as well.
The kind of the practice of
that is fairly straightforward
and in terms of the efficiency
where we use a plugin
into the secrets engine for Vault,
which enables us to generate
those on behalf of tokens.
And that kind of brings us to
the sort of the approach of Kubernetes.
So how are we going to use this?
How do we use Vault inside of Kubernetes?
How do we secure those secrets?
- That is a great question.
So let's dive into this a little bit.
Vault has a capability with
the Vault Secrets Operator
to manage secrets in a
native way with Kubernetes.
So this includes being able
to use dynamic secrets,
PKI certificates, all
the kinds of credentials
that you would want to use
to keep things more secure.
OpenShift OLM supports
it for instant upgrades,
so that also works as well.
Secret transformation is also
something that VSO can handle.
So you end up with templating
that looks familiar
with the secrets on the Kubernetes side
and so that's very helpful.
So basically what happens is
whoever is managing these things
and is familiar with Kubernetes,
not familiar with Vault,
they don't really need to
know anything about Vault
or how Vault works because this
process is all very native.
In terms of identity-based access
and authentication in Vault is processed,
whether it's human or
non-human by providing
identity verification.
And you can see there's a wide range
of different identity providers
that will plug into Vault
that you can leverage
so you can use all of
those identity providers.
And it also is really critical because
most organizations are working
in a very hybrid environment.
You're not just working in, often cases,
one type of cloud, one type
of identification system.
There's probably multiple that exists.
So you need that to be
able to be integrated
with whatever you're using
to centrally manage security,
so multiple off methods are supported.
And then before a client,
whether human or machine
can interact with Vault,
it has to authenticate.
That's really important and
so you need these off methods.
Once that happens, there's
a token that's generated
and there is a policy that
gets attached to that token.
And so whatever entity gets that token,
they can only do what
they're permitted to do
by that policy.
And so right here, Vault recognizes
Nick's different
authentication identities.
It can create credentials
dynamically based on that identity
and then create access
policies based on that as well.
When we talk about
unified identity in Vault,
there's an identity engine
that exists in Vault that
handles this sort of thing.
And when you have a new
entity or identity that is
authenticating with Vault,
it creates that entity.
So it is that one, it has a unique ID,
it is a unique entity to
Vault, but what allows you
to use this in a flexible environment is
you can have aliases.
So there might be different
authentication methods
that are being used for the same entity
and those are aliases that you have.
You can also assign metadata,
you can assign policies
at that alias level.
And so that gives you a lot
of flexibility to make sure
you have that one entity accessing Vault
and wanting to do something,
but you're locking things down
and enabling things for the
various aliases that that entity
might have, if that makes sense.
And this picture here is kind of
what shows that and being
able to enable the RBAC
for those more complex environments
that you find yourselves in with the human
and machine identity.
Audit logs, that's something
that is native to Vault.
They're stored in JSON
making them easy to query.
Vault automatically
hashes any sensitive data
so they're very secure
logs with HMAC-SHA256.
There's a unique salt that's used as well.
So extremely secure
and this allows you to
have that audit trail
for things that are going on with in Vault
because that all gets
logged very securely.
So let's talk about dynamic
credentials a little bit
because we saw in multiple
examples of the attack vectors,
if dynamic credentials had been used,
it would've ameliorated that attack.
So let's look at the first
problem and that was credentials.
So security's all about layered security.
If we stop that vulnerability,
there would not have been
any credentials leaked, sure,
but if it wasn't that attack,
it would've been another attack,
so that's kind of how you have to think.
So we should go ahead and assume
the credentials will leak,
and if they do, you need to ensure
that the blast radius is minimized,
and the only way you're going to do that
is to be able to set
just in time credentials,
ones that have time to live
that can be revoked immediately
to solve that problem.
Dynamic secrets within Vault
are created just in time.
There's a unique ID that is associated
with each one of those credentials.
It's a unique identifier
that allows the secret
to be audited, located,
revoked early if you need to do that.
And every application instance or agent
gets a different credential
with a different time to live.
In terms of the support
for dynamic credentials,
this is a look at the broad range
of dynamic credential types
that HashiCorp Vault supports.
So multiple different types of databases
via the database secrets engine,
cloud service provider
dynamic credentials, LDAP,
and then also security
or certificates like I mentioned
before for PKI and SSH.
So there's no reason not
to use dynamic credentials
when you have all of
that available to you.
This is an example of the
dynamic secrets database engine
and you can kind of see what
the flow looks like here.
Obviously, the secrets
are created just in time
and they ensure that access
is automatically revoked
at the end of the expiry
time for that credential.
And with that, I think we're
going to look at a quick demo
of how this works.
- Yeah, so rather than doing
like a bit of a deep dive,
we can kind of talk about these things
if you want to come over to the booth.
I'm conscious a little bit on time.
But ultimately, the way that
you can configure all of this
just using Kubernetes as an example,
which I think is a fairly sort
of common platform these days
is just through using the
Vault secrets operator,
which is verified,
compatible with OpenShift,
and all sorts of things like that.
And just by using that configuration
through, well, setting up
the database secrets engine,
but then injecting those
secrets into Kubernetes,
we'll kind of skip over this
one for the moment as I said.
If you're interested in looking
at a technical deep dive,
come and find me, be more than
happy to run through those
schemas and processes in more depth.
- Onto the next one?
- Yeah.
- Alright, so let's talk a
little bit about certificates.
I mentioned that as well
and something, especially
using TLS or MTLS,
that's extremely important in protecting
against some of these attacks.
In this situation, in this attack,
if there had been TLS on the system,
then the credentials would
not have been leaked.
Moreover, if there had
been TLS on the system,
the credentials would not
have leaked in this way.
And so that's really important too,
the way that this happened,
so we need to do both things.
And it's not hard to implement
with the right tooling
to make sure you're
using dynamic credentials
and to make sure that
you're using certificates
to enable things like TLS and MTLS.
Vault supports modern PKI management.
And what I mean by that is
very automated, very scalable,
and Vault is flexible too
in the architecture because
you can have multiple intermediate
certificate authorities
that you can configure
based on your environment
and what your needs are.
It can act as the internal root CA
issuing X.509 certificates.
It automatically enables you to
revoke and distribute these
certificates in different ways.
And I'll show you some
of the multiple methods
that it can leverage.
It also has native support for Spiffy.
So the Spiffy X.509
standard, extremely popular
open standard because
it allows you to have
very granular authorization
on certificates
and gives you an easy way to manage
and scale those identities
when you're using certificates.
There's also service mesh
integration supporting MTLS
for service to service
certificates as well.
So let's take a look at
what this looks like.
There's some examples,
so using the Vault agent,
this is where the Vault
agent is actually connecting
to the service or the application.
It's keeping track of the time
to live on that certificate
so when it knows when it's about to expire
and then it will
communicate back with Vault,
and it will authenticate,
and it will request a new
certificate, it gets a certificate
and then it updates that
certificate in the service.
Vault, meanwhile, is keeping
track of all the roles
that are accessing it to get certificates
and then being able to use those.
It also works in a similar way
if we look at the Kubernetes environment,
like we were just talking about.
The Vault Secrets Operator is
what enables you to integrate
with Vault and automate
that certificate management
and have that work in your
containerized environment.
So there's different methods,
if you look on the left,
those are established
patterns using the Vault agent
and then VSO, they're very opinionated,
but on the right, you
also see the capability
to use less opinionated methods
of leveraging this type type
of capability with Vault.
There's the Vault SDK, you can
integrate directly into code
and then you can utilize the Vault CLI
to authenticate and retrieve
one-off certificates.
So there's multiple methods
when we're talking about flexibility
to be able to leverage
certificates with Vault.
In terms of architecture and
scaling, like I mentioned,
you can have an offline root CA,
you create an intermediate CA
that's kind of your
top-of-level wild card domain.
You can have, you know,
a time to live of a year.
You can create another
intermediate CA from the top level.
It's got a shorter TTL,
so you can see how you can architect this
and be very flexible with it.
And then lastly, you have your
instance of intermediate CA
that's going to issue those
leaf certificates for your
application or service
and make that 30 days
or whatever you need to
do, but extremely flexible.
In terms of performance,
compliance, and scalability,
there's disaster recovery
that supports warm standbys
that can be configured for easy recovery.
There's automated deployment.
So if this is something
that you want to deploy
in an automated and scalable way,
you can use Terraform to do that.
You have audit logging that exists
obviously that we talked about,
so you can generate
reports for that purpose.
Cross region support to meet
applications where they are
from a performance standpoint.
And then things like
path filters to ensure
that secrets are not accessed or stored
in Vault clusters where they
may be additional compliance,
so you think GDPR and that
becomes important too.
And if we put it all together,
it's just an extremely
scalable tier zero application
that you can leverage for PKI.
And with that, let's go ahead
and take a look at a demo
of how this works.
- So again, from a sort of a
stance and how you go about
dealing with this, how
do you configure Vault?
it's fairly straightforward
if you've kind of understand
how one of the endpoints work,
they're all fairly similar.
Conceptually, you have
to enable an endpoint.
So with PKI, I enable the PKI endpoint,
I can generate a root certificate,
and then I can configure it.
And once I've got all of
those kind of things set up,
that then enables me to use
the Vault Secrets Operator
to use those roles that I've configured.
Again, it's linked through to the policy
and the service account in Kubernetes,
and it will allow me to inject that secret
from Vault dynamically generated
into a Kubernetes secret.
So from an application
development perspective,
there's nothing different here.
Now if we kind of look
at all of those things,
so if we look at the things
that we've talked about
where the vulnerabilities,
which were core in our demo
were that had we had TLS and
had we had dynamic credentials,
the blast radius would've been
far, far, far more reduced.
Of course, we're looking at
a very, very select problem
and in a very select
area but that's a concept
of defense and depth.
It's not about just doing one thing,
you really have to do all the things.
With dynamic secrets and with PKI
in our agentic application,
if we kind of look through
and replay that attack, you'll
see how things different.
So now we've configured the
server to use PKI, again,
the vulnerability still exists.
So when I find out what the weather's like
and this time I'm going to kind of
ask what the weather is like in Miami
because it's going to be a lot nicer
than it is here right now,
unless you were in Miami last weekend
and you realize that it
just rained for two days.
But conceptually, that same
process has gone through, right?
The sniffer is now enabled.
It's now being sending the
credentials back to the attacker.
And when we use the same thing
using the customer agent,
we'll say, "Hey, give me the
customer order details here."
What that is going to do is
the agent talks to the tool,
the tool makes a
connection to the database,
the database authenticates.
You can see that kind of running
through in the application.
But now when we look at the credentials,
we don't see anything.
And the reason we don't see anything
because the connection between the tool,
and the connection between the agents,
and the connection to the database
is all encrypted with a standard practice
that you've been using for
thousands and thousands
and thousands of hours
and months and years
and, you know, since the
dawn of microservices,
or any form of sort of secure system.
So what are the key differences
with agentic systems and microservices?
And I think the key
thing is that not a lot
and actually quite a bit.
That's a really sort of
ambiguous approach but
the key thing is that agentic
system is very deterministic.
You can't necessarily predict
what it is going to do.
It has this kind of emergent
behavior where it'll just
act on its behalf, it
is more human than it is
that the kind of that traditional approach
where you can just follow
the code path through
either as a single service
or a connection of services.
The thing that's very
much the same is that
a lot of the problems that you've fixed
in your microservice systems
by just employing good
sort of secure practices
around coding standards by
employing sort of secure
systems still applies.
There is nothing really, really different.
But we do have to be aware,
we've got to be planning ahead,
we've got to be thinking
what are the threats?
Because some of them we just don't know.
Like there are things that we know,
but the attackers are becoming
very, very sophisticated
and because of that emergent behavior,
it's opening up new opportunities
that just don't exist right now.
So if you want to learn some more then
we've got some resources here.
You can kind of grab our example
repo and you can kind of,
if you want to run Vault in on
your own or run Vault Radar,
you can kind of get a free trial there.
And of course, if you
want a mode of a deep dive
on the technical side of things please
come and find us in the
expo hall and it would be
an absolute pleasure to chat
to you about those things.
But thank you so much for listening.
I hope it's been interesting.
- [David] Yep. Thank you all for coming.
Hope it was valuable. Enjoy
the rest of the event.